how's that been my congratulations
thanks man it's been amazing
you know she's seven eight weeks old now
so uh it's an amazing journey it's a
cool we're kind of getting in our groove
and figured it all out but it'sit's a
really it's really fun thing to do
especially you know with your wife you
can just kind of take on as a team and
it's cool is it perfect timing and that
you know you're kind of off cycle now
writing an album it was perfect because
we were just finishing up our tour we
knew were gonna have this year also we
could kind of stay at home and work on
some different things and be a dad and
you know kind of help Haley out with
that and we just went away for our
pretty much our first road trip this
weekend away from Haley and Olivia and
yet definitely took some adjusting and
you know it was a different level of
missing being here so you know it's nice
to be off the road and definitely worked
out that's tough mountain you're people
with that because me and Brittany we we
have four dogs we missed our dogs like
three days crazy
this is contagious are you getting the
itch yet yeah yeah I gotta wait a little
bit longer bebe Rexha obviously was a
huge collaboration for you guys meant to
be I don't think anybody expected that
stone to do and it did I mean we knew he
had a special song but for her to
release it in general I think we were
like wow that's amazing and then kind of
was a shot of steroids for our fan base
you know I mean all of a sudden we're
getting streams all over the world and
you know she has a huge fan base
globally and then the song just
naturally blew up and it's fun to see
something just naturally happened
without it really even being pushed or
work you know so then we knew well man
we need to this song feels huge and so
they're like it lets single it to
country radio and see what happens and
then I think they were actually
surprised oh man like now I got a song
on country radio but that's the beauty
of it man and kind of getting out of the
box I'm doing things different and just
seeing what happens and when it works it
works and it works for both parties and
helps each other out the studio looks
amazing from the outside with any chance
I can see the inside of it absolutely
man
let's go check it out there's some
people right right go check out the
rooster up them here comes the exa here
comes here it comes
oh he found himself a hat they look good
it does good you look good in the Hat
Matt you do Matt the Hat hat brothers
I'm gonna work for the rest of the
interview won't see how it goes it's
like it's not property brothers but hat
brothers so clearly we weren't prepared
for any cameras because we hadn't
cleaned up our mess but you guys come
check out the studio so yeah look around
man there's isolation booths back here
vocal booths yeah come on check this out
so we like to keep it simple I mean in
2018 you don't need a whole lot of space
thank goodness cuz we have three writing
rooms upstairs and then we have the main
studio down here and then these
isolation booths but all the writing
rooms are actually connected and wired
to the studio so they can serve as
isolation booths as well upstairs if you
want to track drums or do something
different throw some amps up there but
uh you know we keep it pretty simple and
streamlined and a special place and it's
a place that we feel really proud of and
really honored to have and you know get
to create here it's awesome
IET Canada thank you for joining us Matt
thanks for hanging with us let's hope
you enjoyed the tour thank y'all we're
gonna go write a song now time to go
write a hit so uh you guys just you know
whatever you guys go do do that yeah as
you were as you will get that GL out of
here okay see you